Sam Giordano is joining us he is the
executive director of the American
bankruptcy Institute thanks for joining
us on c-span good to be with you outside
of the obvious why does an individual
declare bankruptcy well it's a matter of
debt consumers are facing increasing
problems from high debt loads they're
also in a situation today as a matter of
the housing crisis home owners are in
many respects underwater on their
mortgages they owe more on the home than
it is worth that makes it difficult to
make the mortgage payment it makes it
difficult to tap into home equity to use
that money to repay other debts and
they're also under employment problem so
employment is high in many states double
digits and people have a problem just
meeting their obligations and when they
do they consider bankruptcy as a way out
from under their debts and once you go
through the process declare bankruptcy
what kind of a timetable are you looking
at to try to get yourself back into the
housing market good credit rating and
the rest well it depends the cases are
very fact-specific
they're 1.7 million projected
bankruptcies this year every case has
its own story in Chapter 7 the debtor is
absolved from most of their unsecured
obligations credit card debts regular
consumer loans that are not secured by
property that is the the laws promised
fresh economic start in chapter 13 the
debtor repays some of their unsecured
debts pursuant to a repayment plan
that's approved by the court proposed by
the debtor that takes anywhere from
three to five years to repay some of
those debts and after that the
individual is generally able to re-enter
the credit marketplace we are a economy
for better or worse that runs on
consumer credit so access
to affordable credit is very important
to till to exist in our society but it
does it does take time people who have
been through a bankruptcy can
rehabilitate themselves but typically
they have problems accessing the kind of
affordable credit that is really
important to carrying on in our our
economy and what are the differences in
the law for personal bankruptcy versus a
business and I'm focusing on small
business it's not large corporations
right individuals as they said have have
two basic options chapter 7 bankruptcy
or chapter 13 businesses typically are
either eligible for a restructuring
under Chapter 11 of the Bankruptcy Code
tends to be more complicated more costly
certainly than a consumer bankruptcy for
those that cannot find a new financing
to rehabilitate themselves through the
chapter 11 process they too can go
through a chapter 7 where the assets of
the company are liquidated and the
company goes out of business and the
current law is making it more difficult
to file bankruptcy is that working and
reducing the number well in 2005
Congress did change the law they made it
more expensive to file for bankruptcy
they created more procedural hurdles for
individuals seeking to extinguish their
debts at first filings did decline well
let's look at the numbers because in
2005 there were an estimated two million
personal bankruptcy filings and about
15,000 business filings compared to 2009
about 1.4 million of the consumer
filings but as you can see an increase
by over a thousand in the business
filings or just under a thousand right
initially filings went down in part
because consumers in particular rushed
to take advantage of what was formerly a
more debtor friendly statute and so
filing spiked in the in the year that
the law went into effect after that
filings dropped off dramatically but
since then they have increased steadily
so that last year for example filings
were up 27%
then this year as I said we're
projecting about 1.7 million filings by
year ramm which would be the second
highest total ever notwithstanding the
spite year so Congress tried to reduce
the number of bankruptcies they tried to
encourage more people to repay debts
through Chapter thirteen that really
hasn't worked mostly because the laws of
economic gravity are more powerful than
laws of Congress people who can't afford
to meet their obligations are going to
look to bankruptcy as a way out of their
financial problems we welcome your phone
calls and if you've gone through
bankruptcy we would especially enjoy
hearing from you as well to hear your
stories and your experiences and your
questions for Sam Giordano 2:02 is the
area code 737 triple zero to our line
for Democrats in two zero two seven
three seven triple zero one for
Republicans you can also send us an
email at journal at c-span comm has the
stigma of bankruptcy gone down in
today's economy well it's hard to
measure something like stigma
empirically or otherwise certainly
people's attitude toward debt and
bankruptcy have evolved have changed
over generations there is less of a
stigma today than there there might have
been two or three generations ago and
that's because I think Americans as
we've seen millions of filings every
year have gotten used to the idea that
bankruptcy is a indicator of economic
failure is a way of life and the law
promises a fresh economic start to
people who through no fault of their own
perhaps need to seek relief from their
debts and the law allows them to start
fresh get access to credit and
rehabilitate their economic future
companies do it cities and towns and
counties do it and so individuals are
are more aware of bankruptcy as an
option they know people who've done it
family members friends and so they know
that there is life after
we've seen the stories you have a house
in Las Vegas or in Arizona or California
maybe two homes and you walk away from
the mortgage you just can't afford it
not bankruptcy but walking away from a
debt obligation what rights do the
individuals have and what rights do the
banks and the lenders have well in some
states California most notably is what's
known as a non-recourse state so the
individual who walks away from a
mortgage is not liable for any
deficiency in terms of the repayment of
the mortgage balance and so that's where
the walk away phenomena as you described
it has become most acute it is also a
problem in other states in Nevada
you mentioned some 70% of the homes are
under water or near underwater meaning
the individuals owe more on the home
than the home is valued 70% state of why
percent right
Nevada is also number one now and
per-capita bankruptcy filings not
incidentally again because of the
bursting of the housing bubble in
addition to the other economic problems
so walking away is is an issue by and
large in this environment banks don't
pursue individual homeowners for the
deficiency the cases they're just too
many cases to to pursue and there's
really no market for the home once the
bank acquires it I guess and redondo of
the american bankruptcy Institute a
graduate of Syracuse University both
undergraduate and his law school
Sam is joining us from Pittsburgh
Massachusetts independent line good
morning Sam do with us
we lost Sam so we'll go to Tony next in
Atlanta good morning good morning thank
you for her c-span's my first time
calling I am a question of a comment my
comment is I had filed bankruptcy just
after I had too much debt my job they
started putting back on hours and wasn't
able to pay you know on my my bills on
time and got me in a bad position I
thought my house note was
1200 hours I had just making a bunch of
changes because of the law when I filed
for my bankruptcy had changed at the
time as well
before the old bankruptcy laws were to
help people get out of debt easier it
seems to me now that I'm paying back my
bankruptcy it cost me more now to pay
the debt off so the laws actually when
they change it actually hurt the
consumers agree or disagree with that
well that experience is not atypical in
terms of the causes of an individual
needing to seek relief from the
bankruptcy law the 2005 law changes
perhaps what the caller is referring to
required some individuals who have the
capacity to repay more of their debts
the law now obliges them to do so
through a repayment plan in Chapter
thirteen it shifts individuals from
these or Chapter seven door of the
bankruptcy court over to chapter 13
where a greater percentage is repaid to
the creditors over a period of time
typically three to five years
Arthur is joining us from Bay City
Michigan good morning with Sam Giordano
of the American bankruptcy Institute
yeah Steve how you doing this morning
fine thank you
just bear with me my comment is going to
believe began in 1963 and 1963 America
was experiencing the same kind of
economic crisis that it's experiencing
now and the IMF and the World Bank were
called in to bail America out and
America began a decline in 1963 it led
to the riots and all kinds of civil
disobedience in this whole tournament
this turnabout drill baby drill that's a
slight on the burn baby burn hero of 60
that led up to 250,000 for white
Caucasian farmers margin down on
Washington own tractors and shutting
down what they ran all the politicians
out of Washington and from that event by
all those farmers led to the election of
Jimmy Carter that
example is what the American people
especially Caucasian people in America
need to wake up and find out what they
need to do to get they go with that RT
need to connect to dust because I'm not
quite sure I follow your analogy so now
she's really genuine crisis will you
banks are fairly your institutions are
falling down and the people in
bankruptcy they have no jobs and now
trade Arthur I well I'll just leave with
that first rate um thank you I didn't
deal with his frustration well he did
mention bank failures bank failures are
also up particularly in smaller
communities the FDIC is on track to take
over more than a hundred banks this year
because of the lingering economic
problems many are real estate are
related and it will take a while still
before that works through the system and
there can be a general health out beyond
the Beltway
if you are saying that the u.s.
bankruptcy is almost synonymous with
unpayable medical costs how are we
addressing this issue medical debts are
a part of the overall debt burden that
individuals are facing many have hope
that the health care bill will make
health care more affordable and will
reduce the incidences of uninsured
medical expenses which can lead a family
to seek a bankruptcy protection we have
a link on our website at c-span org if
you want to get more information from
the american bankruptcy institute this
is what it looks like as we listen to
Charlene from Jacksonville Florida on
the Republican line good morning good
morning how are you fine thank you
good the reason I'm calling is in the
early 2000s I had filed bankruptcy and
it was just a fortune it seemed well
Charlene walk us through the numbers how
much were you earning what was your debt
load and
to declare bankruptcy I had to well it
was against my belief to file bankruptcy
because I worked for Equifax so what I
did was I went out and taught people not
to file bankruptcy so when I filed it
had to file it myself
it was just crushing and before that I
had had a nervous breakdown and had to
go out on disability and that was the
reason that I had to file and so we
finally paid out paid off
chapter 13 got got every solo our ducks
in a row and thanks for going good and
then we both got fit my husband 64 I'm
58 he had a triple bypass I have a hole
in my Pancras and I was I what you'd
call I went into toxic shock they didn't
know if I was going to live or die they
wouldn't even do the complete surgery on
me because they did not think I would
make it so right now I'm home
rehabilitating so I can have that
surgery and all we have both of us are
our social security checks coming in and
for the astronomical amount of bills
that have come in for both of us I mean
we're looking at are we gonna have to
fall again and how long how many years
does it take before you can file again
Charlene will get a response what
happens and you again it was ten years
ago
Charlene when he filed for bankruptcy ah
mm you said maybe yeah is there a
statute of limitations typically the
period is eight years
from one filing to the next it depends
on whether the case was when the date
when the case was converted she
mentioned that she was in a chapter 13
plan a repayment plan as is fairly
typical of chapter 13 plans most fail
about two-thirds fail because just like
as she described things happen but in
those in that eight-year period can you
buy a house can you get
well that's a function of the credit
markets your ability to access credit is
going to be dependent on your credit
score your credit history and obviously
a bankruptcy is going to be a
significant negative with respect to
your ability to access affordable credit
and if you do get it do you pay a higher
rate absolutely
post bankruptcy credit to the Senate is
available is at a higher cost you're not
going to qualify for the best credit
deals that are available Deborah is
joining us from Richmond Virginia good
morning yes good morning how y'all doing
this morning the reason I'm calling is
because I'm wondering whether have y'all
even thought about extending the period
to three to five period of bankruptcy
needs to be extended the reason I said
that when I went bankrupt
I was waiting around for my Social
Security I had to wait four years from
my Social Security I had to have an
emergency operation I had to go out on
disability when you go out on disability
companies or not it's not required to
come this have temporary disability they
don't go by what your doctors say
whether it's whether if the doctors say
you are that they've been unable to work
you can say all that but they they don't
even pay attention to that so therefore
during you know during bankruptcy you
have to come up with the money to the
trustees first you have to keep up your
monthly payments on your own on your on
your house note and everything I mean it
was very very difficult I mean yeah if I
had a husband like one of the previous
callers okay cool I can deal with you
know how much he's but when you're a
single woman who's been working and I
worked almost 30 years at this past job
that I had and then all of a sudden I
had to have emergency operator
I wasn't I didn't prepare for that you
know the the bankruptcy saying that
yeah but it's not no Deborah thank you
for the call and let me take her
situation and broaden it out slightly as
we look at the new health care bill that
was signed into law earlier this year
will that deal with Deborah's situation
and others in her predicament
well I'm no healthcare expert in terms
of finances so in terms of bills that
they may be getting to the cent that it
improves accessibility that will help
what what the caller's have been talking
about are medical expenses that they did
not anticipate or that they had expenses
in excess of their insurance coverage
and again in chapter 13 that is one of
the reasons why these plans often don't
succeed because things happen and
medical things medical problems are an
example of that Sam is joining us from
Pittsburgh Massachusetts thanks for
phoning back again yeah I got hung up on
thank you for taking my call certainly
my question is I recently never I want
to say six seven years ago I filed
bankruptcy and I went through it it was
done went to court you know the whole
thing and we walked away from what we
old the IRS at some point in no two
levies my they said I had a tax lien up
until old seven so it was a substantial
amount of money in my books that he make
a whole lot of money but I paid it off
they sent me a letter from the IRS
saying that I had paid my do everything
was done my question is how do I get
that to the credit agencies so that I
can start building my credits that I
have paid my lien to the secular RS and
you know I've completed what I was told
I had to do and now I need to start
building my credit again how who do I
need to get a hold of to give that
information to the bracket you know good
in cm are you working now I am I worked
at one car company for seven years until
it went bust and then
a changed job and I'd worked 40 50 hours
a week until like four or five months
ago we went to two days a week if we're
lucky okay thank you Sam
the color refers to Internal Revenue
Service debts or tax debts tax debts are
not dischargeable in bankruptcy so
that's an exception to the general rule
we talked about earlier where you get a
general discharge from your obligations
individuals also have a right to correct
information in their credit records that
is inaccurate and so if the caller
received a release from the Internal
Revenue Service for the tax obligation
because he paid it over a period of time
then that document should then be
communicated to the credit reporting
agencies who are obliged to correct the
record based on the new information of
the repaid debt our conversation is with
Sam Giordano he is the executive
director of the American bankruptcy
Institute the web address is a bi world
org rod is joining us from Milwaukee
Republican Lange good morning yes
wonderful c-span wonderful guest I just
want to make three thoughts first of all
a lot of people are going bankrupt and
it's going to increase I believe that we
should put a default on all personal
debt and the national debt and we should
get people back to work by reverse tack
technology reverse engineering a number
of years ago in South America there was
a lot of unemployment in a country so
they because of the modern machinery so
to get these people back to work they
stopped using the modern machinery and
got the people back to work in the
fields and I think that's the only thing
that's going to save our country
reverse technology reverse engineering
I wonder I'll wait for your comment
did you want to respond well having a
job with a sustained income is very
important to not only staying out of
bankruptcy but rehabilitating a one post
bankruptcy and that that's the best way
to access new and affordable credit is
to have a sustained job no question
about it is you go to some of these
strip malls and shopping centers you can
see a lot of for lease for rent signs
and one could only surmise that many of
those businesses either moved out or
went bankrupt if you do go bankrupt and
you want to start up a business in a
year or two how easy or difficult is it
to do so well it's not it's not easy but
it can be done
commercial real estate in general also
seen a rise in bankruptcies you
mentioned strip malls also a larger
businesses who tells office buildings
that need to be refinanced periodically
or having a hard time accessing credit
in the tighter credit markets and so
we've seen a rise in bankruptcies on the
commercial side as well it is possible a
lot depends on the ability to access
credit markets credit has been
restricted over the last couple of years
and until that frees up it will be
harder particularly for smaller
businesses to find the kind of capital
to start up a new enterprise for a
Samuel Giordano next is a Sharon joining
us from Evanston Illinois outside of
Chicago Democrats line good morning
yes time my question is I recently
science events chapter 13 and I'm still
having problems because as my mortgage
comes in and refused to give me a loan
modification yes well actually this is a
great time for this call today as a
matter of fact June 1st a new Treasury
Department rule goes into effect which
requires mortgage lender
and servicers to extend the ham
protection the Home Affordable mortgage
program to individuals who are in
chapter 13 formerly their ability to
extend HAMP coverage was discretionary
and too often lenders did not extend the
program to those who are in a bankruptcy
but now June 1st the program is
mandatory and that allows an individual
to essentially try to right-size their
income for their mortgage to 31% of
their gross income so it will allow the
individual to scale down what they owe
on the mortgage down to that 31 percent
figure and pay that over a period of
time and again this is day 1 of the
program so we don't yet know obviously
how effective it will be I will say up
until this point the government programs
have been largely ineffective in terms
of helping people stay in homes where
they're facing this kind of upside-down
or underwater mortgage situation but but
this program offers some new hope
chapter 7 verses chapter 13 what's the
difference the big difference is the
repayment plan we've had several callers
talk about being in chapter 13 case
plans where they had to repay debts over
a period of time and then things happen
medical expenses other life's problems
happen that frequently causes a
modification of the plan or a conversion
into chapter 7 where those unsecured
debts are extinguished you're going to
lose a home though unless you can pay
the mortgage in Chapter 7 on an ongoing
basis and a hypothetical let's say your
annual monthly income take-home pay is
$5,000 and your mortgage your expenses
your credit card your medical bill is
seven or eight thousand is there a way
that if you are have overextended
yourself that you can go back to your
creditor and say I want to make a
payment but I want to stretch it out
over 40 years or I want to refinance or
I want to come up with a different
payment plan as ofwhat as a way to
bankruptcy what do you do well you can
attempt to talk to your creditors that
is always the first step that people
should exhaust this environment hasn't
been terribly hospitable to those kinds
of offers but as I just mentioned the
the new government program which allows
people to write down the amount they owe
down to something which is more
consistent with their income stream
might allow them to reduce at least
their mortgage payment down to something
that's affordable if they have other
debts that they can't deal with then the
chapter 13 process might help as well
because it will allow the debtor to
simply commit their disposable income to
repay a portion of those debts and the
court will then restructure their debts
as part of the chapter 13 plan Emily is
joining us on the Democrats line from
Houma Louisiana welcome to the program
good morning thanks for taking my call
we had to file chapter 13 while back
when it was unforeseen three heart
surgeries that were unforeseen sorry I'm
nervous
13 as opposed to 7 and we didn't know
anything about bankruptcy and then we
did the plan because we didn't want to
lose our home and then we we finished
off the plan and what is when I was
seeing on what I want to ask you was as
opposed to chapter 7
while we were struggling to make ends
meet at this time and we just finished
the plan out and paid our debt our debts
and and our trustee and everything and
I'm sorry I'm very nervous I I see other
people that had filed chapter 7 and
they were getting credits like getting
new cars and such and I don't understand
that can you kind of shed a little light
on that formula I'd really appreciate it
and thanks so much for taking my call
thank you
is there a disparity again there can be
they're 1.7 million cases there's lots
of different stories out there if you in
the anticipation of the plan of filing
for bankruptcy if you have a for example
a credit card and are able to pay it off
so that you oh nothing to that
particular creditor you don't have to
list a creditor in your case if you
don't owe them a debt they're because
they're technically and legally not a
creditor with one credit line like that
an individual can rehabilitate
themselves and rebuild a credit future
allowing them to get access to other
credit that's one way to rehabilitate
one's economic future another scenario
is where some creditors will look at
someone who has recently been through a
chapter 7 bankruptcy and who is
discharged all of their unsecured debts
but who still has a job who still has an
income stream they may view them as a
better credit risk than someone who like
the caller is struggling to complete a
chapter 13 plan that's because they view
the job as the source to pay their new
debt by the new credit extension that's
ironic in the sense that an individual
who had otherwise discharged a lot of
debt through Chapter 7 has better access
to credit perhaps than someone who has
struggled mightily to complete a chapter
13 plan there are there are cases like
that again it is a function of the
credit market it's not a matter of
federal law our next call is Xavier
joining us from Miami independent line
for Samuel Giordano good morning good
morning yes come to my attention that
there seems to be a system
Masek campaign towards making people
going to bankruptcies by the media and
by this coin administration and that's
the enemy of capitalism you know a lot
of people going into bankruptcy
eventually they don't have bring this
country down it seems to be you know
because you know there actually seems to
be a promotion for people to just give
up on their obligations and I want you
guys to come in on that and I appreciate
it is it giving up on obligations well
again that gets back to the comment we
talked about earlier with regard to
whether there's a stigma left to filing
for bankruptcy our experience and we're
not an advocacy group we don't encourage
or promote people filing for bankruptcy
much like all of the callers that we've
had this morning people are not happy
about being in bankruptcy you sense deep
regret and and frustration in their in
their voices no one wants to be in
bankruptcy and I don't think it's the
government's policy either to encourage
bankruptcy but for 200 years bankruptcy
has been available as a safety net if
you will for individuals who just can't
meet their debt obligations it's in the
Constitution article 1 section 8 that
provides for a uniform federal
bankruptcy laws so it's it's been part
of our legal system right from the
beginning ed is joining us from
Richfield Ohio Republican line good
morning good morning I got an important
question thank you for taking my call I
was my own company I do very well when I
was 24 years old I had a lot of extra
money and I invested into a real estate
venture that completely cleaned my clock
I lost everything how much did you lose
I lost over $400,000 in this real estate
scam it went federal it was the biggest
it was basically I uncovered the rock
for this whole mortgage fraud thing and
what these appraisers were all in on it
was a total nightmare I never recovered
anything but I had managed to save my
business and keep all my business going
and things are going good even though
the economy is pretty rough
the problem I have is I want from a 780
credit score and I'm down to in my it's
pathetic like a 490 and I ate crippled
my business I can't do anything I can't
finance anything I can't grow I can't
get any accounts even though I pay my
bills that I have now I mean and I don't
know if what my best bet is I don't know
if I if I do go file bankruptcy well I'd
be able to repair my credit faster will
I be able to meet the equipment that I
still have loans on and I still make the
payments on monthly basis in color what
is your business and is there a cash
flow to your business right now Oh
certainly certainly I want to keep
supply company and we have a good
commercial and residential business but
you know I need more equipment I need to
grow I need to be able to set up
accounts like that and operate normally
and so this day thing a lot of my
payment terms are 3045 days and it's
just it's hard to do with no no line of
credit or anything I always had that and
now it's gone and thank you I think
we'll get a response rehabilitating a
credit score can be difficult
particularly after a period of economic
downturn the best way to do it is to
repay debts on time the credit markets
as I said earlier are restricted which
makes it difficult for this caller and
others to access affordable credit at
terms that are commercially acceptable
that is a problem that's that's why the
economy struggling no question about it
well we see more bankruptcies in the
year ahead absolutely Steve we're
projecting 1.7 million filings both
individuals and businesses this year
that as I said would be the highest
number notwithstanding the spike year of
2005 Sam giordano of the American
bankruptcy Institute thank you very much
for being with us my pleasure he's come
back again you bet